[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la reelección de macrón y en el segundo
quinquenio del reelegido presidente nos
acompañan en este estudio javier soria
espín profesor de la parís school of
economics bienvenido de exportación
playa forest es corresponsal del diario
danés de la emisora rac bienvenida
gracias y riccardo está la corresponsal
de 'el espectador' aquí en parís
bienvenido recargo y sin más gracias
macrón segunda parte hoy nuestro asunto
en primera plana
[Música]
segunda parte segundo quinquenio una
victoria sin gloria así podríamos
titular el resultado de las elecciones
presidenciales en francia macrón renueva
mandato hasta 2027 entrando en ese
selecto club de presidentes que lograron
repetir como de gol como mi terreno como
si irak pero el quinquenio se presenta
muy difícil el escenario de una francia
fracturada con la ultraderecha y el
desinterés o la abstención en niveles
récord son una realidad macro que quiere
tender puentes cambiando el método pero
a corto plazo el reto parece difícil
porque la batalla por las legislativas
de junio ya está lanzada macro necesita
necesita una mayoría parlamentaria para
articular sus políticas si no se expone
a una cohabitación aunque sus rivales
todo se ha dicho lo tienen todavía más
complicado portadas de la prensa le
monde destaca en un doble titular en
esta portada que la victoria de macrón
pero también la ultraderecha tienen un
nivel histórico el país macrón se impone
al epen en una francia fracturada
también reflejó en la prensa de américa
latina como esta portada del clarín que
destaca el alivio en europa de la
victoria de macro bueno decía yo al
principio una victoria sin gloria en un
país fracturado que titular pondrían
vamos a hacer una ronda rápida a esta
victoria de macrón pedro javier bueno yo
lo que pondría como titular es una
victoria por la mínima nos marcaron
vemos que si a nivel europeo puede que
haya sido bueno pues un suspiro no hay
que mucha gente respira tranquila pero
es verdad que ha ganado por votos
prestados y esto es lo que va a
condicionar el el mandato es decir no va
a tener tanta libertad para gobernar de
manera júpiter y anna como ha hecho en
su primer mandato y esto va a ser la
clave
yo me quedaría con el titular de
liberación que era un país fracturado lo
esencial preservado porque por un lado
es cierto que macrón gana y eso no se
puede discutir lo esencial se ha
preservado que es frenar a la extrema
derecha pero deja un país fracturado y
eso se pone en evidencia en esos
resultados electorales riccardo yo
pondría entre comillas el menos peor
porque finalmente muchos de los votos
los que permite obtener la mayoría fue
un voto para elegirlo no a él sino más
bien para evitar que le pegará el poder
pero esa situación ha pensado en una
segunda vuelta por definición es eso no
una segunda vuelta por definición es eso
de todas maneras visto el margen que
melanson tenía por debajo del epen es
importante que buena parte de los votos
en la segunda ronda
macro no es un candidato que convenza no
es un candidato que hizo campaña y que
finalmente particularmente en este caso
no arrancó favorito no tenía una ventaja
grande y en este caso más que en otras
segundas vueltas cuando simplemente se
confirmó lo que ocurrió lo primero en
este caso es un voto de que había que
elegir alguno alguien tiene que ser
presidente y que sobre todo no sea lp no
siempre es el caso en otras segundas
vueltas el candidato gana cómodamente
porque ya traía sus votos marca en su
discurso habló de una francia fractura
del propio macro dónde esa francia
olvidada que tanto recela de su figura
como tender puentes quizás a la pregunta
ahora que javier que recetas para
vertebrar al país pues precisamente yo
creo que lo que hay que hacer es
revertir todas las críticas que ha
tenido por por por sobre todo por por la
izquierda no un poco el centroizquierda
es donde ha venido principalmente estos
votos no de que le han salvado
finalmente para dar las presidenciales y
es por lo tanto pues eso centrarse en
políticas redistributivas centrarse en
políticas ecologistas que son lo que
reclama pues eso el votante de izquierda
de la falta en su mix de partido
socialista en políticas educativas y
sobre todo sobre todo incluir a los
actores sociales a la hora de gobernar
yo creo que ese ha sido la principal
crítica no que recibo macro
creo que hay que volver a vertebrar esa
francia que se ve obligada
es perfecto de ningún país el problema
que tiene en francia es ese sistema
político que es muy poco proporcional es
decir la elección presidencial es todo
nada entonces hay presidentes que son
elegidos por un 38 40 por ciento del
electorado con altísimas abstenciones y
eso hace que mucha gente crea que su
voto no vale para nada en cada cinco
años faltaría igual un sistema político
más proporcional a representativo más
representativo que a lo mejor conlleva
menos estabilidad no como les pasó
efectivamente ese sistema políticamente
ha estado mucho en esa estabilidad
siempre efectivamente si este sistema
presidencial lo que da es gobernabilidad
garantiza la gobernabilidad y eso es muy
importante evidentemente pero la otra
cara es esa poca proporcionalidad
y mucha gente que se siente perdida
claro porque las olas como son ricardo
en la primera vuelta vemos una
ultraderecha con un 23% melanson una
izquierda con 22% pero luego la asamblea
nacional no tenemos esos porcentajes
repente hay representación macrón matrón
no personalmente no quiere tender
puentes pero tal vez va a tener que
tender esos puentes si no tienen la
mayoría en las legislativas si tiene la
mayoría en las legislativas lo que puede
ser el caso como ocurrió en la elección
pasada y como suele ocurrir en francia
no necesita tender puentes porque puede
gobernar de acuerdo a las políticas que
le interesan y que representa nada lo
obliga él ya no está buscando la
reelección ya no está en campaña nada lo
obliga a buscar acercarse a la izquierda
solamente en el caso en que no tenga la
mayoría absoluta en la asamblea y
necesite puede entonces empezará a
imaginar ese acercamiento
socialmente
y creo que sería lo que tendría que
hacer precisamente para que esa fractura
no sea nuestro que quiera cerrar la
fractura en francia porque quizá quizá
políticamente no tenga esa necesidad
pero si llega un estallido social a lo
mejor esa necesidad se vuelve una
obligación no lo hizo con los chalecos
amarillos había una necesidad de cambiar
de políticas no lo hizo entonces
el método
pero sin embargo es que la propia noche
electoral esa área salía bruno le maire
diciendo que no que la reforma de las
pensiones la iban a no está descartado
que utilizase en el 49.3 que es el
decreto que no tiene por qué pasar por
la asamblea nacional que es lo que vamos
a los frentes van a elegir hola en junio
entonces quiero decir no había ningún
tipo de signo no como decía la ya a la
hora de cambiar lo que pasa es que
silenciarán deja ver también para eso
una cosa ahora y ahora la reforma de las
pensiones está anunciada por macrón
antes de las urnas a diferencia del
primer quinquenio y ha salido ganador sí
pero sí es una legitimidad también
si en cierta manera lo es pero claro es
la primera vez como como comentaba
también ricardo es la primera vez en la
que según los informes los los sondeos
de ipsos vemos que la mayoría de los
franceses quiere que marcaron pierde la
mayoría en 2017 vino macrón con su
frente ciencia y macrón con su mayoría
ahora la mayoría no quiere eso es más ya
estamos viendo que incluso el partido
socialista la pasan su mismo ya han
llegado un acuerdo si tenemos este
acuerdo de izquierdas el último sondeo
nos dice que lograrían la lista más
votada por lo tanto sean nueve puntos
porcentuales por encima de la lista del
macro consiga articular una mayoría
parlamentaria y el reelegido presidente
habiendo anunciado una reforma de las
pensiones previamente ahí tendrá una
legitimidad total para llevarla a cabo
la cuestión es que incluso en los votos
de exar sería un poco inocente pensar
que todas vamos a que todos el
porcentaje votos que se acaba macro ha
sido por sus políticas es decir hay un
voto prestado no como comentaban los
compañeros y ese voto prestado si no se
escucha si no se escucha va a haber otra
expresión social como los y lesionó de
ese corte player si no consigue
consensuar esa reforma va a ser muy
peligroso
la estabilidad social en francia es un
tema de las pensiones muy
potente muy se debate mucho y hay mucha
gente que está en contra de eso él ya
matizó no entre las dos vueltas y los 65
luego bueno vamos a hablarlo solo para
las carreras más cortas es cierto que en
europa se tiende a alargar esa edad de
jubilación pues porque la edad de la
vida también se alarga y porque las
pensiones
todos los elementos del aro y más cuando
el estado necesita ese dinero para poder
garantizar las pensiones en un futuro
entonces la tendencia es esa la cuestión
es como la articula y lo importante aquí
que aunque tenga mayoría yo creo que lo
que tenga que hacer es consensuarlo con
las las fuerzas políticas y con los
sindicatos también ricardo sin embargo
el tema de las pensiones que hacer el
gran tema del régimen veronesi del
mandato no es tan claro que el estado
necesita alargar porque si el tiempo de
cotización es el sistema es estable va a
continuar siendo estable según varios
informes hasta
2050 2060 entonces
la reforma puede ser otro la macro na
dicho yo no quiero poner más impuestos
para financiar las pensiones y
finalmente porque no es decir hay otros
caminos que se pueden explorar no
necesariamente
postergar la de jubilación teniendo en
cuenta además que estamos hablando de la
esperanza de vida pero la esperanza de
vida en buena salud en buenas
condiciones no ha aumentado y sobre todo
hay una diferencia enorme entre quienes
tienen carreras de dirigentes cargas
empresariales carreras de la
comunicación y las personas que están
trabajando como obreros como en los
empleos menos calificados que siguen
enfermando se igual de jóvenes y
muriendo igual de joven disfrutando de
menos tiempos la reforma de las
pensiones va a marcar este inicio que en
que no y sobre todo las consecuencias de
la guerra de ucrania con el poder
adquisitivo que se ha puesto en el
centro de la campaña y consecuencias que
yo creo todavía no estamos bien no vemos
la magnitud que puedan tener no javier
si efectivamente esperemos lo primero
todo el conflicto se pueda resolverlo lo
antes posible a través de un acuerdo de
paz pero sin embargo los que nos vamos a
tener que enfrentar es a las
consecuencias no como decías esta suena
la inflación en toda europa aunque con
diferentes
en diferentes niveles pero porque ha
vuelto la cuestión del adquisitivo a la
campaña eso ha sido antes de la guerra
de ucrania porque bueno efectivamente
las cifras macroeconómicas nos dicen que
el quinquenio ha ido relativamente bien
en términos de desempleo no pero sin
embargo es esto estos nuevos parados
nosotros para los que consiguen ahora un
trabajo de onu empleo qué tipo de empleo
es porque lo que ha aumentado el número
de trabajadores pobres el nombre
trabajadores que no puede pagar su
alquiler de trabajadores que no llega a
fin de mes entonces esto es por lo que
viene la cuestión poder adquisitivo que
además se va a gravar con la inflación
debido al grado cráneo la extrema
derecha perdió a las elecciones
presidenciales en francia pero sin
embargo con un resultado con los mejores
resultados de su historia cómo queda
marín de penn tras estas elecciones la
haya yo creo que imágenes vean
efectivamente ha sacado el mejor
resultado de la historia hay ahora hay
que pensar sí sí ha llegado a su tope o
no se ha tocado ese techo la extrema
derecha pues más allá no puede ir más
allá con lepén o hay que cambiar eso se
verá en los próximos años tampoco está
muy claro ahora cuál es el papel de la
pena qué cuál es el resultado las
legislativas pero está claro que depende
en realidad a pesar de haber sacado el
mejor estado de la historia puede ser
que ya su carrera ya esté acabada que la
extrema derecha elija otro representante
también es cierto que si se ha llegado a
este nivel de votación de la extrema
derecha es por en la transformación que
ha hecho ella el proceso de abolición y
de normalización que habido en la vida
pública francesa gracias a ello ya su
estrategia en gran parte es verdad me
vuelve a perder pero por otro lado el
resultado histórico una 'operación
maquillaje' total que ha consistido en
dulcificar un poco el tono en algunas
propuestas que generaban cierta tensión
entre su mismo electorado como la salida
de francia la europea las ha aparcado o
las ha matizado y esa parece maquillaje
le ha funcionado y ha sacado mejor
resultado pero hay que ver hay que ver
si se puede ir más allá de extrema
derecha o ahí se va a quedar ricardo
porque además hay que tener en cuenta la
aparición de la figura de eric fémur que
bueno a pesar de que su porcentaje en
primera venta no fue tan alto llegó a
retomar las tesis más duras de la
extrema derecha
y los directores de ese muro votaron
lepén entonces hay dos figuras que si se
pueden unir o si se van a unir para
legislativas van a pesar un montón vamos
a hacer en este punto una breve pausa y
enseguida en seguida seguimos tratando
todo lo que hago es si esta reelección
de manuel macro ni los retos y los
desafíos que se plantean en este segundo
quinquenio de macrón será en unos
instantes hasta ahora
[Música]
la guerra está a las puertas de europa y
recuerda horas sombrillas de la historia
la comunidad se organizado para darles
ropa
france24 está pendiente de los
acontecimientos en ucrania
con nuestros equipos en el terreno y
desde nuestros estudios lo mantenemos al
tanto
siga informado siga al día
liberté égalité actual y te seguimos en
primera plana analizando el segundo
quinquenio que se abre para emanuel
macro lo hacemos con los periodistas
ricardo abdalá y laia forest y con
javier soria espín que es doctorando en
la parís school of economics antes de la
pausa estábamos hablando de la extrema
derecha de esos resultados
javier históricos pero también de de si
ese techo de cristal al que llega
siempre la extrema derecha en francia
bueno pues si sigue ahí está está claro
que el frente republicano siguió
funcionando lo que pasa que está en
niveles está raquítico no en los
partidos tradicionales tienen y está de
extrema derecha que siempre que siempre
consigue buenos resultados con el epen
pero que siempre se queda a las puertas
relevo no haberlo tenemos que pensar
principalmente es que macro no se puede
volver a presentar en 2027 entonces
teniendo esto en cuenta es que francia
quiere dejar macro quiere dejar una
francia fracturada que continúe como es
un primer mandato y por lo tanto sea un
caldo de cultivo para que efectivamente
gane la extrema derecha para que por fin
supere esa es el miedo que hay o macrón
quiere entrar pues eso en vertebrar
francia en entrar a francia a escuchar a
los agentes sociales y en crear consenso
con los votos que realmente le han
apoyado y que seguramente se puede
llegar a acuerdos no quizás entre un
grupo de izquierdas y incluso el macro
mismo si eso es la voluntad realmente
que quiere para que no haya un país en
el que tengamos que depender pues eso de
madrileño de personajes conocemos cada
porque el peligro de un hiper centro
como el de macrón es la alternancia
porque la alternancia ya no se puede
buscar en los partidos tradicionales ese
es el riesgo que tiene macrón con su
estrategia de la alternancia de toda la
vida digamos claro macro en lo que ha
hecho es
eliminar de alguna forma la
centroderecha y ciento centroizquierda
cuando él no esté dentro de cinco años
porque no se puede volver a presentar
hay el peligro de que ahí tiene un vacío
muy grande lo que lo aprovechen los
extremos la derecha la extrema izquierda
para aglutinar más y que haya un gran
gran parte del electorado que se sienta
huérfano por alguna forma eso nos lleva
a preguntarnos si ricardo existe el
macro nismo sin macrón yo creo que
existe y yo creo que que allí hay que
hay quejar de hablar de macrón como un
centro porque no es un centro más
fronteras políticas es una derecha
económica que no es una derecha moral
digamos no es una dirección conservadora
religiosa como son otros es una derecha
macro no toma mucho de sus electores
vienen en buena parte de lo que era el
partido de los republicanos el político
de sarkozy que se orientase macrón
porque macro no puede ganar simplemente
y yo creo que el macro mismo no necesita
macro no habrá nuevas figuras habrá un
problema de dwight phillips que pueden
retomar que seguramente necesitan un
poco la bendición en el final del
mandato pero que pueden retomar esa
línea de derecha económica liberal y
europeísta pero pero esencialmente
derecha
y que hablar de mi nación como extrema
izquierda también es un poco un abuso
del lenguaje porque la nación representa
una izquierda que toma el vacío de
partido socialista que desaparece que
prácticamente desaparece en todos los
dos partidos no existen más pero las
corrientes que desean enfrentar extrema
derecha derecha económica liberal e
izquierda pues estarán ahí
independientemente de los líderes aunque
los líderes darán su bendición como como
suele suceder pues en los sistemas
partidistas también podría ser que
macrón tuviera en cuenta que esta
estrategia de no permitir la alternancia
fuera poner en riesgo a francia y los
partidos tradicionales emergieran en
este segundo quinquenio es decir que les
dejara plaza que les dejara sus sitios y
también podría llegar a pasar una hora
que resuciten sí sí que es lo que decía
el compañero es verdad es decir ese
espacio político de sistema sea de macro
pero no olvidemos que macro en 2017 fue
muy listo no en conseguir ganar con esos
votos del centroizquierda no acaparan de
centroizquierda destruyéndolo partido
socialista afuera y ahora sin embargo
vemos que la gran transferencia de votos
ha venido ya en primera vuelta le
votaron mucho más del típico votante de
píxeles ya mundo maicon y la segunda
vuelta una gran transferencia de votos
de píxeles a maicon por lo tanto el
estrés de genio creo que el labio
viernes desde el principio se dio cuenta
de que este país estas elecciones
pivotaban en la derecha y eso me ha
traído progreso que ha tenido muy claro
totalmente pero sin embargo en 2017 que
pasó que ganó también gracias a un gran
apoyo del centro hiciera que el partido
socialista pero sin embargo ha hecho
políticas principalmente como decía no
de derecha conservadora y liberal en lo
económico y además proponiendo ministros
como that man and muy polémico no que ha
llamado incluso al tiempo es moderada
muchos temas entonces el macro mismo
sí que es verdad que digamos que el
espacio político detrás de macro mismo
existe pero sí que es verdad que tampoco
este vídeo todo convencido del todo
convencido de que puede haber una
sustitución tan dulce del macro mismo es
decir personajes como don't feel it con
el bar filippo como un elemento ya son
personas que se ven como muy de derecha
no es difícil que haya alguien no que
pueda capturar todo ese centro y quiere
ese centroderecha y precisamente eso es
lo que necesitamos superar para que haya
un realineamiento no de los espacios
políticos
además creo que tiene la república marx
es que aunque es verdad que el
electorado está ahí no tiene una
filosofía política como partido muy
definida claro como si tienen los
socialistas si tienen los republicanos y
eso va a jugar en contra de ese espacio
de ese macro mismo cuando macro +3 sin
tiempo para pausa ya nos ponemos en la
campaña de las legislativas de junio que
han mencionado ustedes macro necesita
una mayoría parlamentaria y si no se
expone a una cohabitación esto sería
posible ricardo una cohabitación en el
poder que hemos visto a milán son
posicionarse como un nuevo primer
ministro es posible que en muchas
personas decepcionadas de macro votaron
por él solo para evitar que se orienten
así otros partidos es posible y se
perfila ya una coalición entre la
francesa annecy miss y el partido
socialista a mí me parece que esta
colección todavía le falta mucho para
ganar las legislativas y sobre todo los
30.000 ecologistas y partidos comunistas
y los ecologistas no sabemos todavía sé
qué lado se van a orientar y puede haber
una fractura y yo veo una fractura de
partidos y de vista mucha gente el
partido socialista se va a unir al
partido de macrón como ya pasó antes
mucha gente reservistas a nivel parte
matrón yo pienso que más pronto yo puede
tener una mayoría y que está confiado
que la va a tener porque en sus
discursos no habla ni siquiera la
posibilidad de que sobre el sobre el
papel lo tiene más fácil que vamos a
explicar un poco cómo funcionan las
legislativas que son 500 77 diputados
que salen de esas 576 de
circunscripciones donde se hace el mismo
sistema que en las presidenciales y
salían como 577 presidenciales a nivel
micro no a nivel pequeño con una doble
vuelta igual que las presidenciales en
principio beneficia y además teniendo
las tan cerca de las presidenciales al
ganador siempre pasa el ganador de las
presidenciales pero vamos a ver qué pasa
esta vez porque también podría ser que
tú macro tuviera una mayoría pero más
pequeña más reducida que en el primer
quinquenio que es la tendencia que
podríamos aproximarnos y adelantar es
cosas claves lo primero que como
decíamos antes la mayoría de gente
quiere quiere esta vez que haya un poco
de control a más grandes es decir valen
macrón pero pero por el rol por contrato
y la segunda cosa es la unión de la
izquierda no por volver a la primera es
volvemos a lo mismo no sabemos que todas
las encuestas nos dicen que quieren la
mayoría alternativa en el parlamento qué
es lo que pasa cuando vamos a ver si la
izquierda se está uniendo no solo una
izquierda como decía centre com partido
comunista ecologistas el partido
socialista y la fas asumís pudiera
llegar a tener una mayoría en el bueno a
ser la lista por lo menos más votada en
el parlamento no no habría que ver la
configuración porque es tan clave la
inclusión del partido socialista porque
es el partido de la izquierda quien más
estructura tiene pues eso en toda en
toda francia más allá las grandes
ciudades sean no es obviamente por el
porcentaje reducido que salvan hidalgo
sino por el votante tradición el partido
socialista entonces como se presente
esta nueva izquierda unida no a las
elecciones y cuántos diputados para
sacar es lo que va a marcar el nuevo
quinquenio macro metro apenas estamos
viendo macrón estos primeros movimientos
del quinquenio y endo hace dos obreros
se habla mucho de una primera ministra
con un tono social y ecologista es decir
sí que hay indicios que van de tomando
un poco de donde destila macro en estos
primeros pasos también de cara a las
legislativas
de que la primera ministra sea una mujer
y eso es importante porque en francia 30
años que no hay una mujer sólo ha habido
una mujer primera ministra en los años
hoy he visto una
encuesta que decía que el 74 85 por
ciento de los franceses están a favor de
que sea una mujer macrón en su programa
electoral en su programa de partido
defiende la igualdad pero luego como
hemos visto en este quinquenio va a
pesar de que hay ministras mujeres lo
que es el núcleo duro de su gobierno son
hombres en la república en marcha todos
son hombres los los que dirigen en el
elíseo más de lo mismo por lo tanto
estaría bien que predicará con el
ejemplo es la asignatura pendiente de
macrón la igualdad y creo que ahora es
la hora y es el momento de
ricardo creo que la elección de primer
ministro primero ministro será muy
política macro no busca a alguien que
pueda verse como izquierda alguna
persona que ya perteneció al partido
socialista y eso le permitiría dinamitar
la unión del partido socialista para
legislativas es que es importante decir
que no basta con que la izquierda sea la
más votada tiene que tener una mayoría
cómoda porque la derecha los
republicanos finalmente apoyarán a makro
ne sus medidas en francia las
legislativas son o tiene la mayoría
absoluta y si tienes una silla menos en
tu partido no existe no puede tomar
ninguna decisión y sobre todo no puede
hacer una oposición al gobierno no puede
ser una moción de censura es lo que pasa
durante el primer quinquenio y es lo que
permitiría macrón seguir adelante con
todas sus reformas aunque tenga una
mayoría de un de una sola curul pero a
lo mejor el rodillo no es lo mismo una
mayoría aplastante que una mayoría
raquítica no técnicamente sí con un voto
de más le basta para pasar sobre
técnicamente sí pero mejor hay que medir
un poco como pudiera funcionar yo creo
que sí que podría haber diferencias no
depende un poco como
sí bueno yo creo que estamos en la media
hora con el compañero pero sí que es
verdad y sí que es verdad que no
simplemente la mayoría parlamentaria es
lo que va a jugar en este quinquenio
sobre todo para el espacio político de
macri llamó y bueno y quien pueda
sustituirle no o sea va a jugar mucho es
atiendes a agentes sociales hace es una
digamos una mesa pues eso incluyendo a
sindicatos etcétera etcétera del medio
ido entonces hay que tener cuenta que la
izquierda a los agentes sociales no van
a estar únicamente en el parlamento que
sin duda es importantísimo que hay una
unión que hay una buena campaña que
entiende sacarlo lamer parte posible ya
no nos engañemos porque esto va a ser lo
principal pero sí que es verdad que de
manera secundaria
como todos los agentes sociales puedan
influir o por ejemplo si hay un
movimiento transversal tanto después de
personal sanitario el personal educativo
etcétera etcétera muchas luchas que se
que se unan y que creen un poco como
como de como decía la ya no está esta
marea de contestación social es un verbo
a marcar el quinquenio ya que macro no
tiene que incluir a esta gente uno de
los problemas que siempre se achaca
francia
es la cuestión que me gustaría terminar
es no saber ubicarse en el mundo como
gran potencia del pasado venida a menos
con una plaza mediana en el mundo actual
es pesar de una grande del pasado que ya
no está
creen que ese mal le afecta a makro no o
él tiene una consciencia del lugar y de
esos límites que tiene el país ahora
mismo es un problema del país como lo
enfocan recargo en el principio la
guerra en ucrania cuando macrón llamaba
putin casi a diario y en el elíseo nos
hacía como nos contaba lo que había
pasado diciendo que habían tenido una
charla muy cordial y una hora más tarde
el crimen decía pues macrón llamó y
había que contestarle porque hay que
contestarle pero yo creo que macro y fue
muy fue muy visible o sea él creía poder
ser el mediador el el hombre al que
putin escucharía y pues a putin no le
importa pero natural todavía se ve como
el el salvador esa obra es algo
extrapolable a la sociedad francesa
yo creo que francia todavía es un
poquito nostálgica de ese lugar que se
ha ido perdiendo en europa y en el mundo
y en europa sigue teniendo ese lugar que
en europa el eje franco-alemán es muy
importante es muy relevante que francia
tiene en la política europea un peso
inigualable y además en este momento en
que la presidencia alemania la canciller
merkel ya no está y está soles macro na
y ha aprovechado para mostrar su
liderazgo y creo que lo está haciendo
quizás porque scholz políticamente aún
no ha llegado al nivel de
la dependencia del gas ruso de alemania
con el que tiene problemas alemania
bueno muchísimas gracias a los tres ha
sido un placer compartir este en primera
plana con ustedes y a partir de hoy se
escriben la historia de este segundo
quinquenio de macrón ya todos ustedes
hasta la próxima semana en primera plana
gracias
[Música]